yvan colonna était dans le bureau du
juge antiterroriste laurence le vert cet
après midi à paris l'assassin présumé du
préfet erignac était interrogé pour la
première fois sur le fond du dossier
il clame toujours son innocence clément
weill-raynal dit ça bat rarement une
arrivée au palais de justice aura
suscité un tel luxe de précautions le
transfert d' yvan colonna ce le fait
plus escorte armée mais l'île de la cité
est également protégé par une
surveillance aérienne ainsi que fluvial
on n'est jamais assez prévoyants pendant
toute la journée
yvan colonna a été interrogé par le juge
d'instruction antiterroriste laurence le
vert
yvan colonna continue d'affirmer qu'il
n'est pour rien dans l'assassinât du
préfet claude erignac
pour le moment la justice ne dispose que
de deux éléments à charge les aveux des
membres du commando qui ont désigné yvan
colonna comme l'assassin du préfet et
les quatre années de clandestinité passé
dans le maquis corse
une cavale sur laquelle yvan colonna
devra forcément s'expliquer pour moi et
une cave homme signe rien du tout ce qui
ce qui va être établie c'est les charges
précises
et que ces charges se confronter aux
déclarations des autres et persiste à
dire qu'il n'y a aucun élément matériel
qui viennent corroborer les déclarations
qui en sont c'est une remise en cause
nous verrons par hier aussi que ce
course d'autres problèmes nous évoquons
vendredi matin devant la chambre sociale
dont quillan colonna continue de plaider
son innocence les tms en 1906 record est
innocent les avocats d yvan colonna
entendent notamment demandé une
confrontation avec les autres membres du
commando qui ont désigné yvan colonna
pendant leur garde à vue avant de se
rétracter plusieurs mois après cette
confrontation sera l'un des moments
essentiels de l'instruction